Dancing with the Stars host Tom  Bergeron's mom has died just months  after his dad passed away the 60 year  old star announced the sad news Saturday  on Twitter with this pic he captioned  the shot four months apart together  forever rest in peace mom just one day  earlier Tom shared at this picture quote  four months ago my mom lost the love of  her life  now we've gathered at her bedside they  never did it like being apart after  sharing the news  Tom announced he will not be at Good  Morning America for the Dancing with the  Stars cast announcement Tuesday so he  can attend his mother's services instead  Tom says he will be back to work when  season 22 of the show kicks off March  21st